Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz has
now eliminated any doubt whatsoever that
remained that yes he is a completely
disgusting and immoral human being we
are going to look at a couple of
examples here uh in the first couple
segments of the show at the hypocritical
and disgusting reactions from multiple
Republicans to the latest news that Mike
Pence also had classified documents at
his home now later in the program and
maybe tomorrow even we're going to look
at the rise of immediate conspiracy
theories surrounding the classified
document story involving Joe Biden and
Mike Pence but for now let's look at the
pretzels that some of these Republicans
are twisting themselves into and
sometimes very brazenly Ted Cruz
appeared on television with Larry Kudlow
Larry Kudlow I guess after working for
Trump he got a show back now on Fox
Business and as you can see if you if
you're watching Kudlow just looks like
he really enjoys himself when he hosts
these shows doesn't he and Ted Cruz
started talking about oh well the the
FBI needs to investigate not only Joe
Biden but hunter Biden because of
everything that's going on and Larry
Kudlow to his credit
plays a sort of soft Devil's Advocate
and says well I don't know I mean you
know Pence also had documents there and
Ted Cruz I don't know don't worry about
that we know where those documents came
from do we take a listen to this then
this shifts from a political problem to
a very serious problem of criminal
liability and and Major Crimes and so
the API needs to search the University
of Delaware archives and they need to
search Hunter Biden's home and business
address
um just as an addendum to this the news
came out today I'm sure you saw it that
former vice president Mike Pence a
friend of both of ours he's found some
classified documents it turns out that a
friend of both of ours is a big factor
here I think in his home in Indiana not
in his office uh what do you make of
that is this different from the Biden
story does this just like I know this is
totally meaningless Senator but like
just so I can say I put the question on
the record there's no similarity is
there complicate the story are we going
to continue the bull market and special
councils I'd rather have a bull market
in stocks than in special councils how
do you see at Santa Cruz
Oh look The the Mike Pence story it's
still early uh you know Mike Pence and
as you noted he is a good friend he's a
good man he's explained where these came
from what his office has put out is is
that in packing up the vice presidential
offices that that there were a couple of
papers that were classified that were
inadvertently a couple inadvertently
with non-classified materials that was a
mistake but there's no reason uh to
think it was anything but inadvertent
there is no reason to think that the
Biden stuff was anything but inadvertent
listen it's not partisan for me it's not
even partisan as some of our our friends
across the the pond like to say there
are right now three situations we know
about Trump Biden and Pence I have no
reason to believe that the Biden one is
anything but inadvertent if the facts
change I will revise my opinion I have
no reason to think that the Pence
situation is anything but inadvertent
the facts change I will revise my
opinion I have every reason to think
that the Trump situation is deliberate
given the dozens of different data
points and and reports about Trump
directed people to do this once the FBI
a national archives became interested in
the documents they're on video moving
the documents around rather than simply
packing them up to be turned back over
to the National Archives the fact that
Trump pushed his lawyers to lie and say
we gave you back what we have even
though Trump knew that they hadn't it's
piece of evidence upon piece of evidence
these are three situations two seem
benign one seems deliberately criminal
that is very very different from what
Joe Biden has done Joe Biden has given
zero explanation as to how these
classified documents got there and in
particular
he has given no explanation as to how he
has documents from his time in the
Senate listen yeah so um as as many of
you of course know the Republican party
and people like Ted Cruz are numb to
hypocrisy it's astonishing hypocrisy
it's it's mind-blowing and they are
completely numb or immune to it there is
no political punishment for it in fact
often they are rewarded for maintaining
the party line the way that Ted Cruz is
doing and at the end of the day what the
hell do you expect from a guy who had
his wife called ugly by Donald Trump and
then turned around and supported Trump
and talked about how great how great
Trump is now there's another side to
this okay maybe we see it as hypocrisy
but they don't what I mean by that is
they might see it as we aren't
Hypocrites we are good and Democrats are
bad we deserve power Democrats don't we
are above reproach even for the same
things that we criticize democrats for
doing doing and that's it right it could
be a means justify the end sort of thing
and that they fundamentally deserve
different treatment and different
considerations even for the same things
when applied to Democrats that's a
possibility
the other is they're just Hypocrites and
brazenly so and why would they stop
being Hypocrites given that they are
never punished for it so that's Ted Cruz
let's now go to another example of this
this you have to see
Elise stefanic Republican congresswoman
from New York
explains how what Mike Pence did was
fine
and Trump was treated unfairly for the
documents document stuff but Joe Biden
is a national security threat that's the
that's the real issue here there are
three stories here two of them the
Republican ones are not a concern but
the Biden one that is the real issue
let's take a look at this and she starts
talking about a weaponized FBI and blah
blah blah blah folks we have three
situations we can analyze them pretty
clearly and this is not the way that the
line is that the uh the the uh what
would
I'm I'm searching for a metaphor here
let's just listen
Joe Biden uh he has had classified
documents going back to his time in the
Senate where he started serving before I
was born so this is a long-standing
national security threat setting aside
the very important fact that Hunter
Biden also had access and used as his
home address where those classified
documents were improperly and illegally
stored does she realize the number of
people that have access at Mar-A-Lago
like if she's concerned that Hunter
Biden sometimes went to his dad's house
she is going to be stunned to learn what
happens at Mar-A-Lago with regard to who
could have have that have had access to
the boxes of documents that Trump
directed to have placed down there we
don't even have evidence Biden knew he
had this stuff we don't have evidence
Pence knew he had the stuff let's
continue
this will be a part of the oversight
agenda and on the house intelligence
committee we absolutely want to make
sure we have all of the facts
[Music]
well let's highlight the difference here
in what the consequences have been you
had the FBI raid Mar-A-Lago you did not
see any of that happen for President Joe
Biden you know why you know why there
was a different handling because the
legal uh law enforcement authorities
trying to get the Trump documents back
spent months trying to get them back
through other means with Biden and with
pence in Pence's defense Pence did the
same thing there would be no opportunity
for a raid or search warrant to be
executed because the amount of time
between when the documents were found
and turned over was so small that's why
they're among many other reasons by the
way
what also is different is President
Trump as president has the right to
declassify documents that that's a ruse
okay he has the right to he didn't and
legal experts are almost unanimous on
the fact that just saying pack up my
documents and send them to my house does
not de facto declassify them just
because the president does it
for a sitting president
what a rhetorical pretzel that Elise
stefanic has wedged herself into it may
not Shock you that Elise stefanic was a
gleeful endorser of George Anthony
kitara De volder Santos you know who I'm
talking about right the guy who invented
the heart transplant technique and built
the Eiffel Tower that George Santos
anyway she was lovingly gleefully and in
Dorsey an endorser rather
um of Santos shouldn't come as a huge
shock at some point I actually do think
that this will maybe not backfire on
Republicans but just fall flat and what
I mean by that is if you look at polling
and approval polling so far Joe Biden
has been unaffected by the classified
document situation my guess as to why is
that the American people realize there
is no evidence of any kind of malicious
intent or subterfuge whereas the Trump
situation is dramatically different and
Trump's approval continues to suffer I
think the American people are actually
smart enough to know and that's a phrase
that's often used by by Republicans to
say I believe the American people are
smart enough to realize what's be you
know when socialism it just really
genuinely seems as though people realize
the difference between the Trump
document story and the Pence Biden
stories which right now look relatively
similar although differences may come up
in the future let me know your thoughts
is it clear to you
that we are dealing with dramatically
different situations here in terms of
trump Biden and Pence with these
documents or do you think that it's
basically all the same thing let me know
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
at youtube.com slash the davidpackman
show and make sure you're following me
on Twitter at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
in case you thought otherwise the David
packman show continues to be funded
directly by our viewers and listeners
through the membership program you can
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
instant access to commercial free audio
and video streams of the show there's
the daily bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah we'll make money
on the uh on the bonus show so what Alex
and also now available to our members
the soundboard my soundboard that I have
here Obama
you have access to it as a member we've
put up a soundboard on our website and
it's a really really great thing sign up
at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code if
you want 24 starts now a pumpkin orange
sweaty and slurring Donald Trump is now
giving marching orders to Republicans
who have taken control of the House of
Representatives I don't know that
they're listening to Trump I don't know
that they care what Trump says anymore
some of them anyway but Donald Trump put
out a video two and a half minutes long
telling Republicans exactly what he
expects them to do we have not digitally
altered this video this is really
Trump's physical appearance this is
really Trump's voice notice also the
jump Cuts done terribly Trump really
struggles to record this drivel so they
often have to take it a sentence at a
time usually when you do this you do the
jump cut from a different angle so it's
not obvious that it's stitched together
um with with Trump it's just a disaster
everything about this video is a
disaster Let's Take a Look new house
committee on the weaponization of the
federal government is a rare chance to
expose the breathtaking corruption
of the security State the media and the
Washington swamp is Trump okay I mean
that this level of sweating I almost
wonder whether the orange fake tan is to
cover something else going on his eyes
are almost completely swollen shut like
slits I mean it it it it does not look
good
here are just a few of the questions the
committee hopefully will be asking who
in the Mueller team was in charge of
leaking okay so this was a smart jump
cut they actually went to the side
secret information and fake news stories
to dishonest journalists of which are
many to perpetrate the Russia hoax and
that's what it was turned out it was a
total hoax it was all
misinformation it was all a horrible
thing that was given to the people of
our country
illegally by a fake press at a corrupt
press and understand that there was
nothing illegal about the Russia probe
Nothing by corrupt politicians today the
fake steel dossier was first published
because they knew it was fake and they
knew that sometimes there'd be a guy
like Trump that wants to go after them
have any fake news journalists been paid
or compensated by U.S government
agencies directly or indirectly for
their role in spreading domestic
disinformation like the FBI did with
Twitter who orchestrated the FBI's
repeated operations to interfere in
domestic politics I genuinely don't
think Trump even understands the words
he's reading off the prompter he seems
lost in the prompter and completely
disconnected from the meaning of what
he's saying 10 weeks of multiple U.S
election Seasons right and specifically
and most importantly
in the presidential election of 2020
what the FBI did was suppress anything
bad about Biden
and go all out
put it all out there if it was anything
at all bad about Trump and if there
wasn't anything bad we'll make it up
now none of this is true I I know you
know that and of course he doesn't cite
any examples that was as a rigged
election just by itself for all the
federal agents and that jump cut was so
bad they cut off one of Trump's words
who's editing these things performance
and pressing the crowd toward the
capital
on January 6 and who is raps tell me
about raps where does he come from I
think we know this is Trump feeding this
conspiracy theory that Ray Epps a man
who was videotaped in DC the day before
the January 6 riots the the idea that
some right-wingers have is that he was
actually an FBI either informant or
actual agent of course there was no
evidence of that
whatsoever and
there's just no evidence of that
whatsoever period
in addition the committee needs to do a
full review of Pfizer warrants any abuse
we should also get a full report and
they're an audio glitch that was in the
video just so you know it's just a
disastrous video any domestic
surveillance of Maga supporters
that has taken place under Biden
or Obama and the radical left season
is very in fact deep seated
it's a deep-seated deep State the
greatest threat American freedom in
Generations has seen and their collusion
with the fake news media is absolutely
atrocious
this committee is a vital chance to
bring it all to life this is arguably
the worst that Trump has sounded forget
about how he looks
struggling to put together these words
and of course he is pretending as though
he is now going to direct these
ridiculous committees that Republicans
are putting together the weaponization
committee their covid committee which is
not really a coveted committee it's sort
of like a get fauchy committee Trump
believes he is now going to direct
Republicans in their uh investigations
if that's what you're going to call them
maybe he's right I am not going to
assume until we see is Trump still in
control of the Republican party or is he
not his endorsement record in contested
races in November was not particularly
good as you know
um and so we'll see whether Republicans
are going to listen to Trump or not but
he really doesn't look good and uh the
rallies I guess are starting soon this
weekend there's going to be it's called
an event I guess it's not really a rally
I don't know what it is in South
Carolina I told you Trump was struggling
to find state legislators willing to go
up on stage and support him uh our
correspondent Luke Beasley is going to
be there interviewing people and
hopefully some of the questions Luke
asks will be about like do you still
think that that this is the guy that's
good for your party uh but real it's
just Amateur hour in every way the
reading the filming the audio it's
completely Bonkers let's now go from
talking about the guy who wants to be
president to the gal who wants to be his
vice president we know how great it went
for John McCain to select Sarah Palin to
be his vice presidential running mate in
2008. so naturally the next step is for
Trump to choose Marjorie Taylor Green in
2024 right and indeed it has been
suspected that she wants the job
it has now been confirmed that Marjorie
Taylor green does indeed want that job
we suspected that the lunatic extremist
conspiracy theorist Marjorie Taylor
green was desperate to be Donald Trump's
vice presidential running mate now we
know it and this is the continued Jerry
springerification of the Republican
Party
Marjorie Taylor Green's dangerous
conspiracy theories and horrible
statements obviously have no place in
the White House they have no place
within a heartbeat of the presidency but
when it is the modern Republican party I
don't assume that it's out of the
question NBC news reports Marjorie
Taylor green aims to be Trump's VP pick
in 2024. former Trump 8 Steve Bannon has
spoken with green and says quote she
sees herself on the short list for
Trump's VP now whether she is on Trump's
shortlist is a completely separate
question two people who have spoken to
Green say that she is trying to be the
VP this is no shrinking violet she's
ambitious she's not shy about that nor
should she be said Steve Bannon she sees
herself on the short list for Trump's VP
paraphrasing Cokey Roberts when Marjorie
Taylor green looks in the mirror she
sees a potential president smiling back
a Second Source who has been advising
green said quote her whole vision is to
be vice president the source is tied to
Trump and spoke on the condition of
anonymity said he also believes green
would be on Trump's shortlist the goal
is at the heart of Green's recent effort
to Rebrand herself as a politician who
can stand to stride The Divide between
the party's hideliner hardliners and its
establishment Wing so understand that
this sheds major light
unto why Marjorie Taylor green after
saying for years she is not part of the
Republican establishment it explains why
she criticized those who dissented from
supporting Kevin McCarthy for speaker
just weeks ago and joined those who
support Kevin McCarthy she sees an
opportunity and you know what Marjorie
Taylor green is out of her mind but
she's not
stupid
in the sense that she recognizes now
that Republicans are going to control
now that the Republicans do control the
house
she can be on one side or the other she
can be one of the detractors of
Republicans within the house or she can
be on the side of we are now in power we
are legitimate people to be taken
seriously rather than the clowns that
many correctly see us to be and so she
has decided to put herself on the side
of the speakership and of the
establishment Republican Party
clearly this was all to try to make
herself more palatable and to be taken
more seriously
to potentially be Donald Trump's running
mate now she is out of her mind she said
the 2018 California wildfires maybe
there was a Jewish space laser that was
a factor she has alluded to the 9 11
attacks being a false flag event in the
sense that she said she's not really
sure that a plane did hit the Pentagon
she has talked about shootings
potentially being hoaxes or hoax-like
she of course is one of the biggest
promulgators of the obvious to any sane
person lie that the 2020 election was
not really won by Joe Biden but rather
stolen by Biden and actually won by
Trump this is what we might refer to as
a dumpster fire of an elected official
and not only does she want to be Trump's
VP there are people who would vote for
her to be the vice president that's
maybe the most frightening thing now
admittedly it may be a relatively small
portion of the Republican party I don't
know we're going to find out I am sure
that she is being vetted among with
others to potentially be potentially be
Trump's VP but thinking ahead many steps
Trump as president was humiliating
enough for the United States okay
if somehow Marjorie Taylor green became
the vice president it would be even more
embarrassing let's hope it doesn't
happen because it would also endanger
our national security in all sorts of
different ways but Marjorie Taylor green
we knew it and it's now been confirmed
she wants to be Trump's VP we'll have
more on all of these stories on our
Instagram find us on Instagram by
searching davidpackman show find me on
Instagram at david.pakman
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to welcome back to the program today
Corey in my focus to say his last name
correctly I almost call them Carrie
Corey doctorow who is a science fiction
author activist journalist and blogger
his latest book is choke point
capitalism how big Tech and big content
captured creative labor markets and how
we'll win them back particularly
interesting now in the context of all of
the concerns around tools like chat GPT
T and Ai and the impact that they may
have on Creative labor markets maybe
just to start somewhere Corey we start
there what's your sense very big
disruption coming from these tools or
maybe overblown
you know I think that um as interesting
as the hypotheticals about what will
happen when these markets mature and
start taking away jobs from creators can
be to think about it's pretty
speculative
um there there are elements of what GPT
does that and other ml tools I don't
like calling them artificial
intelligence they're neither artificial
nor intelligence but these machine
learning tools
they're also not learning but what they
do what they do uh sometimes amounts to
something that I think is um absolutely
legitimate and the kind of thing we want
to encourage which is thinking really
hard analytically about how art is made
and then making new art that's how I
became a writer uh and you know uh
irrespective of what tool you use to
make your art uh it will always include
some element of Automation and always
include some element of analysis and
making something new by analyzing the
things that came before you it that is
not just legitimate it's how art emerges
and you know one of the things that
we've learned and that chokepoint
capitalism tries to emphasize is that
when you have an enormous amount of
Market concentration right there's
there's five giant Publishers four giant
Studios three giant labels two Giant ad
tech companies one giant ebook and
audiobook company that that giving
exclusive rights to creators is not a
way to get them paid more it's like
giving bullied kids extra lunch money
you know if you have to do a deal with
one of those companies to go live then
they're just going to take whatever you
got and so you know not long ago there
were a slew of Music lawsuits over kind
of look and feel or groove of songs the
first one was a lawsuit over the song
Blurred Lines that argue that it just
sounded like a Marvin Gaye song yes if
there was any notes from a Marvin Gaye
song Rhythm from Marvin Gaye's song
lyrics from Marvin Gaye's coach you know
uh key changes or or chord progressions
but that it just in its totality sounded
Marvin gayeish and um the victory in
this lawsuit was kind of a heralded in a
mixed Way by both by record industry
Executives and by performers
um but ultimately I think you know with
three giant record labels uh if it does
turn out to be the case that there is
such a thing as a groove right and that
becomes well established in law it's
just going to become a feature of the
normal record deal that when you sign a
record deal you sign away your groove
rights and what that means is that whole
genres will become the property of three
companies and there's just going to be
no way to make new art without
submitting to whatever terms they demand
of you that would be the worst case
scenario of creating a new right to
control how people can make new art out
of what they've learned from looking at
your art now there's a much easier case
which is the plagiarism case yeah right
that's where that's where machine
learning just coughs up whole sentences
paragraphs images figures from from
other art that's a lot easier that's
just copyright infringement uh in in the
main
um but I think that even if they could
guard against that and and as a kind of
pretend computer scientists have an
honorary doctorate in computer science
um I can imagine a pretty easy way to
compare uh output from a machine
Learning System to training data from
the system and ask yourself is is this a
direct lift and if it is then you then
you um uh discard it and start over and
I think that even if that were happening
all of the concerns that people have
about creative labor markets would would
still persist with machine learning
images uh um words and so on if we step
back a little from the creative side and
content creators and talk a little more
generally on the one hand there are more
and more ways in which Computing
generally and by this we might be mobile
devices Computing generally is kind of
integrated in every aspect of people's
lives jobs shopping travel you know
quite literally every aspect of people's
lives there is a maybe a growing
realization from some about the power
that big Tech has both in terms of
guiding people's choices and in terms of
data in all sorts of different ways
there's a growing realization I don't
know that it's really completely
widespread on and understood in the way
that maybe someone like you would would
hope people would understand what is the
direction of this in terms of what where
this is taking us as a 5 10 or 15 year
timeline yeah you know there's a kind of
Galaxy brain meme version of this right
where you know first you have this
inkling that some computer technology
some digitized element of your life is
adversely affecting you yes right and it
should be better then you realize oh
well this is pervasive across all of
society then you see some muscular
action taken in one corner and you see
it Ripple out across all these other
areas in unexpected ways so for example
um you know the copyright notice and
takedown system that was created in 1998
in the Digital Millennium Copyright Act
really changed the way that we do
copyright enforcement for the digital
era you know when I worked at a
bookstore if you thought a book on the
Shelf infringe your copyright you didn't
just get to march in and say take it
down right right you'd have to like get
an injunction and show evidence and if
it was frivolous you'd face penalties
now under notice and takedown you
literally just send a an email to any of
the intermediaries right so they can be
a payment processor it can be a cloud
provider it can be the ultimate
application provider like YouTube it
might even be an application an
application conduit like the app store
or the Google Play Store and you just
say there's some infringing material
here you need to take it down and by and
large that's what happens that turns out
to have all kinds of weird consequences
right you get cops who play Taylor Swift
songs when people try to video record
them in the hopes that YouTube's
copyright filter will automatically
remove the content you get reputation
management companies that are really
just reputation laundry companies uh
there's one in Spain it's quite
notorious that works for convicted
torturers murderers human rights abusers
war criminals and it uses fake copyright
notices to make news articles about
their crimes disappear from the internet
you know and so this is the next stage
where you're like oh wait
we need to do this with care and then
you know for me the Galaxy brain stage
the part where you get to the where you
go oh wait there's like a way through
this is to say that
um all of the impediments to making good
evidence-based policy about tech do not
stem from Regulators merely being a
little clueless about technology
Regulators are capable of acquiring a
clue about technology there's no
microbiologist in Congress and yet we
all managed to drink our tap water
without dying of microbial illnesses
um but rather that when an industry is
very concentrated you know when the web
is five giant websites filled with
screenshots of text from the other four
it's very hard to have an uncaptured
regulator every time you try to do a
proceeding everybody who shows up from
industry tells the same story even if
that story isn't true and you get kind
of Twisted and distorted regulation that
redounds to the benefit of those firms
and that's why we need to demonopolize
the internet and that's when you realize
oh wait Google is not a company that's
an idea Factory Google is a company that
buys other companies that have good
ideas Google itself has made one and a
half successful products it made a
search engine and a Hotmail clone
everything else that's made bought from
someone else or just copied from someone
else like Chrome which is based on some
open source code uh abandoned by Apple
ironically
um and and uh you know the the um uh you
know the the products that it launched
internally Google video Google Plus and
so on these all just crashed and burned
it it hasn't made a success in-house so
you know if we were to apply antitrust
laws as they were written instead of as
they've been practiced for the last 40
years and just so you can't buy your
nascent competitors you can't merge with
major competitors you can't acquire
vertical monopolies you can't collude
with your competitors to rig markets as
Google and Facebook have done with their
Jedi blue program to steal money from
Publishers you know they're not stealing
your copyrights they're just stealing
your money uh that um you know if we
were to apply those laws then we would
have a very different technology
landscape and a lot of these problems
could be much more narrowly focused we
could say to a company that's doing
something wrong hey this is your conduct
remedy here's after you you have to
change your your ways and clean up your
act rather than creating these these
policies that Ripple out through uh
these individual companies that control
so much of our lives so if we step back
for a second from the antitrust and sort
of regulatory piece of this at the
individual level is this just like the
ship has sailed in terms of like unless
you are quite literally going to opt out
of using devices leaving any footprint
on the Internet it's just sort of like
yeah I don't know like using a VPN is
not really going to make a big
difference here like is is there
anything that individual Behavior even
has as a role to play here so I think
that that in that we need to talk about
Monopoly again to talk about the role of
individuals because one of the things
that made Monopoly possible was this
ideology of consumerism and this idea
that it you that the way that we make
the world a better place is by shopping
carefully that your political
participation amounts to being an
ambulatory wallet uh you aren't going to
shop your way at a monopoly capitalism
but you never were going to shop in a
way that would prevent Monopoly
capitalism you know if you go down the
grocery aisle uh and um you pick up the
product that is a low packaging
alternative because you care about the
environment to some major product it's
going to be made by the same company
that makes the high packaging
alternative it's going to be made by one
of two companies Unilever or Procter and
Gamble the two companies that make
almost everything in the grocery store
and if there was a product that was
successful against them if there was
like some local like dude and a leather
apron who is making hipster cookies and
uh everyone was buying them and they
became a runaway success uh either
Procter Gamble or Unilever would buy him
out yeah and they did they'd issue a
press release that said we bought this
company because we know our customers
value choice right well you you can have
any choice you want except for the
choice not to enrich the companies that
are doing bad things which means that
there is no choice for cleaning up
Society to clean up Society you have to
be part of a movement systemic problems
need systemic Solutions the second half
of choke point capitalism is a bunch of
shovel ready solutions that are quite
Technical and have no individual role
except for the role of making these part
of the ideas that are lying around when
crisis strikes because when uh things
that can't go on forever will eventually
stop and when they do there is the space
in which ideas that have been in the air
about how we can make contracts fairer
how we can make business fairer how can
we give individuals performers and
workers more rights that's when they
come to the force so you know for years
people have been talking about what we
lost when unionization went away
as an individual you can't improve the
conditions of the workers at your
Starbucks but when 100 Starbucks moved
to unionize because that idea is in the
air because the crisis is struck then
you as an individual have a role to
support the union they'll tell you how
they'll say here's our strike fund
here's the day that we don't want you to
you know we don't want you to buy
Starbucks gift cards this Christmas you
know they they will give you ways that
you can act as an individual as to
enhance the the action of a movement but
in the meantime what you can do is is
find out what the systemic problems are
talk about and socialize those systemic
Solutions and then be ready to deploy
them when the moment comes aside or in
addition to the Monopoly and antitrust
issues what else are the big big Tech
concerns to you in terms of you know
funneling people into a uniculture or
whatever right I mean I'll just leave it
open what else should we be concerned
about so you know I wrote another book
uh that also has the word capitalism in
the title it's the season for those
books called how to destroy surveillance
capitalism yes and and it argues with
shoshana zuboff and her book uh in the
age of surveillance capitalism whose
core hypothesis is basically that ad
Tech is a kind of mind control Ray and
that uh while it might have been
invented to sell your your nephew fidget
Spinners it's been hijacked to make your
uncle a q Anon and that's where all of
this collapse and our support for
institutions comes from it comes from
the persuasive power of AD Tech I don't
think that's true I think that you know
ad tech companies their their greatest
persuasive power is convincing people to
buy ads and that's always been the ad
industry's greatest power but I do think
that people's uh um confidence in our
institutions has collapsed because our
institutions are are not worthy of our
confidence right when the NIH lets
moderna uh um make an mRNA vaccine using
NIH patents without taking a license and
then doesn't step in to assert that
patent when moderna quadruples the cost
right uh and and Scoops up for itself a
four thousand percent margin on this
vaccine that was produced with 10
billion dollars in public money that
that is a reason to doubt the our
institutions and that monopolies pervert
our institutions and so you know to the
extent that ad Tech helps you find
people who are disillusioned it doesn't
make those people disillusioned and the
way that ad Tech makes people
disillusioned is by abusing our rights
not by being persuasive but by for
example effectively blocking privacy
regulation which we still don't have on
a national basis in the United States I
I think in a world where we are privacy
is so comprehensively invaded so
frequently and so uh visibly when our
Regulators don't step in to give us a
privacy regulation then that that makes
the claims of conspiratorialists who say
that our our agencies are captured
shouldn't be trusted and so on it makes
them credible not because Bill Gates is
putting microchips in our vaccines but
because the agencies themselves haven't
earned our trust so that's I think the
main problem of of big Tech is that big
Tech makes the claims of
conspiratorialists credible which makes
it harder for us to rebuild our
institutions which we really need to do
lastly Corey you know you you are so
well known for issuing these
extraordinarily important critiques of
the system out of sheer curiosity do you
do anything at the individual level that
people might find interesting like you
you stick with an old flip phone just or
you know anything like that
no you know like this is the thing so
I'm not I guess the biggest thing is
that I'm a Zucker vegan I don't have any
Facebook accounts or Facebook adjacent
accounts I'm not on Instagram I'm not on
WhatsApp I'm not on Facebook I'm not on
Facebook Messenger but you know that
doesn't help at least or except at the
very margins because Facebook still has
a dossier on me all right apps on my
phone are built with Facebook sdks which
means that uh they're Gathering data for
Facebook uh and and and Facebook is
maintaining it
um you know I I there are only so many
hours in the day yes I am pursuing
systemic changes right and so if I stop
pursuing systemic changes to pursue
individual ones then I'm going to lose
efficacy there's a great bit at the end
of zephyr teachout's wonderful book
break them up about antitrust where she
says if if you spend three hours driving
around looking for a fair trade mom and
pop magic markers to make a sign so that
you can go to the strike against to
Amazon and you missed the strike because
you didn't want to buy your markers from
Amazon Amazon wins yes right and so
rather than taking these meaningless
individual steps at the margins I try to
take big step big swings at the center
uh you know that said like with Arts
artistic work
um I I try to buy it in the way that
gives the artist the most money so with
music that means when there's an artist
I love like most recently it was
Penelope Scott I go and buy their whole
catalog on bandcamp which does give
significantly more money to the artist
than listening to them on Spotify okay
interesting yeah I I agree with you
wholeheartedly about the broader broader
philosophy there um the latest book is
choke point capitalism how big Tech and
big content captured creative labor
markets and how we'll win them back
we've been speaking with the book's
author Corey doctorow always great
having you on really appreciate it
likewise it's a it's a great pleasure
nice to see you again David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well my friends you did something quite
notable over the last 72 hours remember
that on Monday I came to you with almost
tears in my eyes and I told you about a
disaster facing many creators Like Me on
YouTube and I asked you take some simple
steps simple actions and many of you did
and the results are stunning and they
have turned up quite a bit of
interesting information now before I get
the results I'll quickly remind you what
went down on January 9th mysteriously
there was a six hour period during which
our live analytics on YouTube showed
that we were getting almost no views not
like 10 less than we normally get but
almost zero some hours we got 1900 views
when we would normally get one hundred
thousand views this impacted our Channel
it impacted other people in and out of
left-wing Politics on YouTube YouTube
told us your views are fine it's merely
a reporting list which we're gonna fix
the glitch but views are completely fine
the next day things were supposedly
fixed and after three to four days some
slightly higher numbers were
retroactively updated in our analytics
for that weird six hour period on
January 9th but views were dead the
channel was dead subscribers were flat
one day we even lost subscribers after
gaining subscribers basically every day
for years and years we actually ended
the day with fewer subscribers than we
started
since January 9th the Channel's been
anemic videos that after 90 minutes
after two hours have two thousand or
fewer views again something that hasn't
happened for years do the math you know
that this is just a mathematical reality
we come to to learn these things from
doing this for so long with 1.6 million
subscribers the mathematical possibility
of ending up with 2 000 views on a video
it doesn't pass the sniff test views
down 60 70 percent Revenue down 60 70
percent subscribers at a crawl happening
not just to our Channel but to the
channels of others you know as well so I
asked you to do something really simple
first search YouTube for David pakman
click on one of our videos in the
results do it a second time do it a
third time the key is search for me and
then click on my videos we are training
the YouTube algorithm when you click on
my videos make sure you are subscribed
many people watch the clips but don't
subscribe that's bad for us Us in the
algorithm and make sure after
subscribing you click the bell and
select that you want to be notified
please like the video I said and if you
can please leave a comment the idea was
if YouTube shows you my videos in the
recommended videos you click on another
you comment you like you keep a string
going
this if nothing would show that if there
was nothing nefarious that took place
maybe we fell out of the algorithm
because of that glitch on January 9th so
maybe we can fix it so here's what went
down as soon as that video went live on
Monday at 4 pm Eastern explaining what
was going on we started promoting the
hell out of this video we dumped every
resource we had massive dumps to
artificially Drive traffic to the video
as much as we could the video picked up
over 450 000 views as of yesterday and
even more now and something incredible
happened that video generated more than
000 new YouTube subscribers but did it
fix the algorithm is the next question
well
yes and no
the next video we published meaning
Monday at 5 30 Eastern was a video about
Donald Trump's absurd eulogy of diamond
from diamond and silk and that video did
okay it got about 200 000 views still
really good so it seemed as though the
activity from the 4 pm video did help us
in the algorithm when the next video
went live but after that things sort of
went to crap again but there are some
really important takeaways here it seems
and again we are working with zero
transparency so we're just kind of
feeling around in the dark it seems that
we can force our content back into the
recommendation engine it seems that the
dumping everything we had into that four
o'clock video did lead to more
recommendations for the 5 30 video but
then things trailed off things aren't
sustaining themselves the way they used
to so for now the good news is if we
keep at it if we keep trying to retrain
the algorithm in this way as I'm talking
about it might pay dividends it also
might not okay so please keep it up keep
up the like comment subscribe stuff now
I I also want to mention because people
have emailed me and said David you sound
extraordinarily naive I am not so naive
that I believe we can fix this ourselves
alone
and reporters have reached out to me
since this video went out they're
talking to me and other YouTubers about
what's going on I'm hopeful that an
article or more than an article will be
written about what's going on and
published soon to maybe shine more of a
spotlight on this in the meantime please
keep doing these things they are simple
and they are free and if you can afford
it get a membership at joinpakman.com we
are down in Revenue dramatically we were
counting on the YouTube Revenue to
launch the Spanish language YouTube
channel which is scheduled to launch
soon so if in addition to those free
things you can get a membership for a
couple bucks a month you can do that at
joinpakman.com of course you get the
bonus show why not oh the bonus show
where you want to make money better
somebody else that makes money to fund
themselves as bad you get the whole
thing and you can use the coupon code 24
starts now to get yourself a discount
but thank you I mean just incredible
what folks have been able to do you know
how the right is about small government
and not getting government involved in
stuff unless it's absolutely necessary
well it turns out that's not really true
multiple Republicans are now demanding
hearings over DirecTV dropping the right
wing Channel Newsmax now if you didn't
hear about this what happened is as
follows companies exist that make
decisions one of those companies is
DirecTV
the David pakman show is on DirecTV
we're on a channel called Free Speech TV
I believe it's Channel 348 on DirecTV
although it might be 9415 and we're on
348 on on Dish I don't remember anyway
we're on DirecTV on Free Speech TV
DirecTV could decide we don't want Free
Speech TV anymore they could decide that
for any reason they could decide that
because Free Speech TV is left wing or
because they don't like my face or
whatever right the DirecTV could decide
that they're a company that can make
decisions as long as those decisions are
not illegal based on some narrow
regulation that exists well DirecTV is
deciding they're going to drop Newsmax
now why are they doing it I don't know
is it because Newsmax is right wing
maybe that would be their right is it
because people aren't watching Newsmax
on DirecTV maybe is it because they want
to replace it with Golf Channel number
seven maybe they can do that and this is
a private business making a business
decision the way Republicans always say
is what should happen
not anymore let's start with our first
clip here is Senator Rick Scott saying
we need Congressional hearings into this
by the way do you realize what's going
on with health care and climate and
education and the debt ceiling and this
is what we need Congressional hearings
about and if anyone knows how to balance
a budget it's you you were the governor
of Florida
for quite some time and so I know that
the house will be shall be thankful to
have you help them with ideas I don't
ask you about this we've had about 40 of
your colleagues in the house send a
letter to a T and direct
warning of hearings and demanding to
know why conservative platforms like
ourselves are being censored and pushed
off of their off of their lineup what
would you say to that and are there
efforts in the Senate
um to try to dig into why they're
censoring conservatives
absolutely we've got to get to the
bottom of this this censorship by
companies like at T of conservative
voices what Google does what Facebook
does remember
so God
this is called the fire hose of
falsehoods it's not censorship
for companies to decide what channels
they want to carry sometimes I might
like the decisions and sometimes I might
not it is not censorship secondly we
just had a study that revealed the
claims about Google's bias are untrue
there have been studies about Facebook's
bias and it found actually conservative
political content is usually the best
performing stuff on Facebook he just
squeezed three lies into five seconds
and people watch the stuff and they go
he's probably right you know well you
watch we you know what what Elon Musk
has put out about when Twitter did this
has got to stop so we need to we need to
hold hearings here we need to get the
bottom of this I'm going to do
everything that I can they already got
rid of another uh conservative Network
earlier uh or sometime last year now now
Newsmax this that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to shut down our
voices and we've got to fight for this
the American public have to show up so
so if you're watching call in t say
you can call in TNT and tell them you
want Newsmax absolutely you can do that
but Congressional hearings using the
power of government to investigate cable
lineups satellite TV lineups Congressman
Michael Waltz says there should be
Congressional hearings as well 41
members of Congress have uh have signed
this I've got it right here a letter to
DirecTV calling uh calling on them to to
address this uh your name is on that
list uh where does that go from here
something like a you know a letter like
this uh that you send to to the uh
people that run DirecTV and ATT what
happens after that
well you know we have a number of
questions in that letter that will
demand answers for uh you know it could
go so far is to have their Executives uh
come to talk to us and explain this to
us why did you get rid of the show is it
because you don't like the look of Sean
Spicer's suits on Newsmax tell us the
truth in terms of the both the timing
and the intent uh and it could go as far
as the timing doesn't matter and the
intent doesn't matter they are free to
decide what channels to have writing
public hearings wow but I I think the
public hearing should be part of this
broader effort uh and and you know from
the left to essentially snap everybody
in line with their view their way of
thinking uh or you can't get access to
anything you need to actually function
as a company or a business yeah yeah
listen
um as you can tell Republicans taking
over the house has immediately put them
laser focused on the issues most
important to the American people oh wait
no it's actually not
um here's one more here's Congressman
Jeff Van Drew saying uh we need to do
hearings before there aren't any
conservative voices left no question
about it and it's not self-indulgent
because the bottom line is what he means
is it is self-indulgent
um what this country is about is freedom
of ideas freedom of vision which applies
to DirecTV DirecTV has freedom of ideas
to determine what they want on their
Network DirecTV has freedom of vision to
determine how they want their Network to
play out freedom of discussion freedom
of speech and I would be angry if they
were strictly doing that to a liberal
sure you would a group of people or a
liberal you know magazine or a liberal
newspaper or anybody that represented
one side or the other the point is we
should be able to have our viewpoints
and they should be able to be expressed
in this particular case it's real
obvious something's wrong because there
are stations that are on DirecTV that
don't do as well as you there are
stations that are on DirecTV that don't
it sounds like the Republican here is
saying DirecTV should use the metrics he
thinks should be used to decide why does
DirecTV have to decide about Channel
lineups based on what is most viewed
that that's for the government to tell
DirecTV that's how you have to decide is
extraordinary overreach I can't even
continue with this nonsense because it's
so crazy listen to the bottom line of
what's going on here
they claim that they are against
government regulation they don't want
government overreaching government
should stay out of stuff unless
absolutely necessary except all of a
sudden they want government to force
Twitter
to publish covid disinformation and all
of a sudden they want government to
direct the conversations and decisions
made by doctors and women in medical
settings about abortion and they want
government to decide what types of sex
are legal talk about sodomy laws here
the way Ken Paxton recently said would
be completely defensible in Texas for
Texas to do they love the free market
until the free market dumps them DirecTV
wants to dump Newsmax and they can do
that will this fix inflation no
they claim that that's a real issue
which by the way has been coming down
for months will this fix the issue of
the dead or whatever else all this stuff
um will anyone get health care as a
result of this of course not these
people are pathetic and they are
dangerous and this is the type of stuff
unfortunately many Republicans have
elected them to do they want them doing
this sort of thing it's sad but it is
not altogether surprising we have a
voicemail number 2192 David P speaking
of cancel culture here's Peter from
China saying I am a counselor
hi David this is Peter from China yeah
on your recent show you once again said
that cancel culture was something that
didn't really exist and we should quote
push back against the concept of cancer
culture end quote
so David a few months ago when you were
encouraging your audience to call their
cable provider and complain about Fox
News being among the channels provided
what would you call that if not cancer
culture
or is that just a case of activism going
too far no it wasn't either many people
don't realize that they if they have a
cable subscription are sending a few
bucks to Fox News people who dislike Fox
News are funding Fox News many people
don't realize Fox compared to other
networks is more funded by cable fees
your cable fees than by advertising
relative to other networks so I told my
audience if you're displeased with Fox
News you can choose to make your voice
heard you don't want your money going to
Fox News you can call your cable
provider that's not cancel culture
that's me telling people if you want
there to be consequences to the things
that Fox news is saying and doing you
can choose to call and tell your cable
provider you don't want to pay for Fox
News this is exactly the point this
isn't cancel culture it's consequences
to the actions of people based on the
things they do and say I don't know how
many times I have to repeat it but Peter
from China doesn't seem to get it we
have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about my pillow Mike
lindell's RNC cam chairmanship campaign
we will talk about lawyers ready to sue
on behalf of three students over that AP
black history class that Ron DeSantis
wants to cancel and 70 declines in one
month of AD spending on Twitter what on
Earth is happening over there get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at joinpassing.com
foreign